ik hoorde hier matleners
laten we eerst de problemen
oplossen die er nu al liggen
dan hoop ik ook dat de PVV van mening is dat we nu
tegemoetkoming moeten regelen
voor mensen die nu geconfronteerd
worden met hoge prijzen
we praten hier over 1 wet
die de gemeente vergaande bevoegdheden geeft
om mensen
van het gas af te dringen en naar zijn warmtenet
toe te sturen
dat is waar we het hier over hebben
u constateert
eh 4 zei ik 4 de voorste in dat probleem
dat heel veel mensen nu met betalingsproblemen
zitten en dat het gewoon 1 puinhoop is
ik zie het in Rotterdam ook
allemaal mooie beloftes die niet waar worden gemaakt
moeten we die mensen helpen
ja ik denk het wel
maar daar moet wel financiën voor zijn
want iemand moet die rekening betalen
en de vraag is wie betaalt het